we interrupt this program to bring you
Courage the Cowardly Dog Show abandoned
as a pup he was found by Muriel whales
in the middle of nowhere with her
husband Eustace Bagge ah but creepy
stuff happens in nowhere
it's a stupid dog you made me look bad
Judy I'll go my name goes hi and welcome
to you
I mean Sierra anyway it's good to be
back with another week of Friday last
week we hit 1 million Sabri Sabri and
this week we got 1 million 100,000 which
is just ridiculous brothers I thought I
told you to stop at 1 million but you
ain't stopping so it's ok it's ok I
forgive you it's pretty crazy how things
I've been working out it's insane
I'm I'm happy right thank you and it's
it's hard to talk about it without seems
not grateful because I keep joking about
it but I couldn't be happier about being
so popular on YouTube right now I know
it's gonna fail like everything else
it's not it's not that but
I don't know I'm just happy about it and
I feel like I never expected to happen I
keep this dress I'm just a mat I'm just
uh I'm just a regular guy who likes to
play freaking video games and that
that's really all there is to it so it's
um it's it's I am really baffled by it I
I didn't stop talking about it
what what's that sound
what is that sound you hear it Bros
she's coming from coming Oh gimmicky no
hearing one key I'm saving got turn your
video shut don't say that out loud me
I'm recording this on my webcam because
my regular camera broke I don't know why
anyhow uh speaking of who yet there's
this video or this picture in the last
prize you could buy that it's just
spread like crazy was insane I'll show
it here um it's it's ridiculous I think
you got like 20,000 reblogs or likes on
tumblr which is it's insanely high I
don't think I've ever seen a high it's
hilarious and it's disturbing at the
same time right Koga don't Photoshop
that she loves her don't you you smell
like you farted did you fart oh yeah
yeah come on [ __ ]
there's still a lot of bros who wanted
me to address the fact that there are
channels that gets hate and because
they're saying are you plated okay
did pop lay my hand on you i hate i hate
on you Sean
I don't need personally I get the same
thing I get the same thing from other
channels
I get other fans being on like oh you
copy
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and I
don't care it's like I know I'm not
copying them sorry I don't see how it's
offending anyone how you can really be
offended by I just ignore it
billiad or lock it if it's really a
problem and I feel like if I could talk
about this every single time era and
there was still the people keep talking
about it so I feel like I'm wasting my
time it's obvious I told I said it
before I'm not I don't appreciate that
you hate on other channels I don't
deserve it
I'd be smart about about it and don't
troll because then my brother's name
controlling breath a mean I mean the bro
I also just wanted to warn you bros next
week I am going away to Sweden going
back to my roots yeah yeah I'm going to
just say hello to my friends and family
to just relax and enjoy summer I guess
not saying in front of the computer
freaking fine I will miss you bros I
will be gone for a couple of days out
there won't be any Friday's good goodbye
Friday right back or anything like that
so I'm sorry I'm sorry I want to remind
you that the forums you can go there
check it out
talk to other bros and we also got hash
tag now on Twitter which is hash tag
hashtag bro type hashtag bro time that's
what it is and it's pretty much easier
for me to communicate with you browsed
on Twitter that way because um I get so
many tweets in my feed saying oh I liked
it video from Peter Pan I favorited
which I really appreciate I really
appreciate that you brought us take the
time and actually like it's all of my
videos I don't know how you bros do it
but I it's it's taking the bro army
where we are today so I always
appreciate you leaving ratings in common
it actually does help a lot so but yeah
so if you want to talk try to talk to me
use the bro tag talk to other bros that
use the bro tag or use the forums it's a
great way almost listening to
suggestions through you can put
suggestions on the forums and I always
go there I get I got slender from there
so it's pretty cool about stuff like
that I wanted to show a little new thing
I wanted to do every Friday food fight
I'll new on out I'll destroy it all
right breast basically I said like a
intro outro of this transcript I'll just
put on whoever has the interest
PewDiePie or
that enough for on omegle video chat and
we'll see if we can surprise
the gum breath it's nice to meet you can
you hear me
hi hi oh no oh you can Terry oh yeah
sure you okay hey what's up
not much mm-hmm I send you a message in
Utah all right two days ago uh-huh
please do you check you to me say yeah I
check my god I think that usually takes
me a couple of days to answer them so
hang in there and I'll try my best for
you so you obviously watch my videos
which ones are your favorite Hey
everything everyone that's awesome which
since when you play amnesia ah that's a
classic you just do it
I've tried to apply amnesia but I it's
so scaring ah I haven't you don't load
it in my computer but I I can open it
because I'm so scared
haha I know that I know they're feeling
that wait a moment I need to take a
photo should I pose okay this is good Oh
Oh buddy okay what oh there yes time I
know I know I'm looking at yet if it
will be my uh my mmm paper wallpaper ah
I honestly can't believe me
well I gotta go now
it was really nice talking to you all
right let's time with the brofist
okay prepare Oh beautiful yeah
but okay but we should be back to me now
again I've been rambling a lot this
episode I'm sorry I can't hear back
gotta hide your face although I'm
creeping you bros out with all the
creeper faces but I'm well it's Lud how
you enjoying that photograph it's
getting isn't it um again stay awesome
guys I love you breath I love you and
that's why we end this with a barefaced
if you're new if you're new you gotta
broke this if you are old you got you
have to because you already broken so
you can't bro fit once and not breakfast
if you watch these videos this long and
not brofist you're on your bow okay I'm
sorry
I love I've always forcing this year I
just stay awesome bros you make my
dreams come true
this breakfast pheromone activate
you